在《红楼梦》里死亡是一种常态。从开边一时,林黛玉的弟弟和母亲就先后拒世。其后假瑞、林如海、秦可亲、金串、游氏子妹、秦文等人物、君未能投脱与命的结局。曹雪芹便借用一机两名之法,对《红楼人物》展开侧面刻画,家宝玉就是一个典型的例子。
原住地32回,金串跳进自尽,家宝玉因此被父亲吃他,握床不起。在这个过程中,家宝玉做了一个梦,原住是这么写的。
这里宝玉和婚默默只见讲玉汉走了进来,诉说中顺府拿他知识,又见金串进来哭说为他投井之情,宝玉办梦办行都不在意。
虽然曹雪芹对家宝玉的梦境,只用了短短几十个字进行描绘,可当中运含着对家宝玉这个人物的深刻抛弃。
金串为什么要跳井自尽?曹雪芹设计的张回名是韩迟如秦列斯金串,可见金串困于被年走的迟如经历,所以才选择自尽而往。
在家宝玉的梦里,她却觉得金串跳井是为了自己,所谓金串进来哭说为她投井之情,也就是说,家宝玉的欲响和现实其实是分裂的,她活在自己幻想的情感世界里。
对于家宝玉的这从心里,曹雪芹没有潜尝折指,如果说金串之事,曹宫写的比较了草,那么秦文之死真可未不令比莫,写的格外详细。
第七十七回,秦文被年出一红院后,家宝玉一夜间再次做了一个梦,她梦见秦文向自己告别。
直见秦文从外头走来,仍是往日醒景,进来笑像宝玉道,你们好生过吧,我从此就别过了。
说必翻身便走,宝玉忙教时又将习人教醒,习人还只当她惯了口乱教,却见宝玉哭了,说道秦文死了。
家宝玉这个梦不幸误重,秦文当天夜里确实驱适了。
第二天,家宝玉叫来压缓,秦文去世前的具体情况。压缓说,秦文姐姐直着薄子叫了一夜,今日早起就闭了眼,住了口,事事不知,也出不得一声,只有倒气的氛了。
家宝玉听完秦文,秦文半夜叫的是谁?压缓回答,叫的是娘。家宝玉觉得不可思议,秦文还叫谁了?
小压缓说,没有叫别人,家宝玉便说,你糊涂,想必没有听真。
很显然,家宝玉再三寻问,就是想要从压缓口中听到这样一个答案。
那就是,秦文叫的是宝二爷的名字,跟秦文之死的信息获取不同,秦文之死没有目击者,家宝玉可以进行的幻想,秦文之死则有压缓,秦儿听到他临终之言,家宝玉没有听到自己喜欢的答案,就责备这个压缓糊涂,听得不够仔细。
秦传之死,秦文之死,二者的文笔描写几乎是平行的。
秦传去时候,家宝玉暂搓涂一箱,秦文去时候,家宝玉渡转女儿累,这都是写进张回礼的大关节,可这种秦的根源却是基于一种幻想式的虚望,独者几乎怀疑家宝玉有人可面具。
按照指币的暗示,红楼梦结为有警范情绑,家宝玉的平语是秦不秦,一直家宝玉对不秦之物关注了太多的秦。
具体可见第三十一回,斯善子做千金一笑,此回更成本有回钱批语约。
斯善子是以不秦之物,共交称不知秦时之人一笑,所谓秦不秦。
基于英元已定,又协议金秦林是建设法也,和平而为其所感,故平而为秦秦。
直言摘这里用林代玉家宝玉所对比,产是秦秦与秦不秦的区分。
林代玉心中在乎家宝玉,这种在乎会让代玉变得关心则乱。
所以无论是缺宝拆的金索,还是史相云的金秦林,都会让代玉百般紧张,担心自己和宝玉的未来会受到影响。
这就是秦秦的含义,也是代玉最可爱的一面。
家宝玉则是秦不秦。
善子明明是无秦之物,家宝玉却说,善子原是善的,你要思着玩也可以使得,只是不可生气时拿他出气。
眼然把善子当成有秦之物来对待。
包括第十九回,家宝玉也曾担心宁古府书房挂着的美人图会寂寞,于是专门去书房又去陪佩这位美人,结果壮见明烟和万儿的丑事。
可现实是,善子就是善子,美人图就是一幅画,他们并不具有家宝玉幻想中的情感价值。
除了这些无秦之物,还有不知情的人,包括今串秦文。
他们对家宝玉并没有产生灵代玉士的爱情,直言摘将他们称为不知情实之人,所以今串跳进不是为家宝玉讯息。
秦文去世的业里也没有叫家宝玉的名字。
可宝玉却对不知情之人有情,这才误认为今串为自己而死,觉得秦文死前一定喊了自己的名字。
这并是秦不秦的深刻内涵。
秦不秦三字贯穿了家宝玉的一生。
学界研究家宝玉形象之,无故寻求密恨,有时似傻如狂,也都脱离不了这三个字的解读。
也只有带着秦不秦的吃意,家宝玉最终才能彻底动物,完成悬崖撒手的最终一月。
能把人物写到如此入目三分的程度,古典小说中,出红楼外,再无第二本可奇迹了。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。